my name is Percy Jackson
am I a troubled kid yeah you could say
that bad grades bullies
all the normal stuff and then there's
some stuff that's maybe not so normal
you saw something
something that no one else could see
[Music]
the stories that I have told you about
Greek gods and half-bloods they are real
Mrs Jackson things have changed since
it's all developing a lot faster than we
anticipated over why is your half a goat
in your pants
so the important thing is not to panic
Percy Jackson
we've been expecting you
[Music]
the master balls
has been stolen
that is your quest
[Music]
remember what I taught you
you're gonna need to be brave now
[Music]